hey guys before we get into today's
episode just wanted to really quickly
address that there's a lot of social
injustice going on in the world there's
a lot of systemic racism happening black
lives matter there's no debate about
that we don't want to get into a full
episode about it because we don't feel
like we are the voices that need to be
heard right now we don't want to get in
the way of the message but there are a
lot of voices that you can go and listen
to we highly encourage you to do that
and I mean Nikki's being nice about it
oh we have a few things to say to Jess
all I gotta say is [ __ ] the po-leece
mm-hm and I gotta say stop [ __ ]
shooting peaceful protesters who
[ __ ] yeah and if you're out there
protesting please be safe know your
rights and just practice as much safety
as possible we support you fully 100%
just be safe take care of each other we
love you guys guys so today's episode
involves conversations of sexual
harassment assault and rape I know those
are very very sensitive topics and this
is to be honest probably our most
serious episode we've ever done so just
a trigger warning for anybody who is
sensitive to those topics we're going to
be discussing them so you've been warned
hi everybody welcome back to another
episode of big moon we got four of us
here today we got Nicki TIFF Jess and of
course there's me Gina and hope you guys
had a good week today's episode is going
to be about something that's been going
on around Twitter something that I am so
proud of everyone speaking up for male
or female and I think it's something
that we can all a lot although most of
us can relate to and that is sexual
harassment sexual assaults and you know
all the experiences that we had because
me as a woman I know that you know I've
been through it
99.999999% of women that I know I've
been through it all so men have gone
through it too so this is a very
important topic for me because I feel
like there's a lot of people out there
who don't know how to put their voice
out there
and from what I've seen on Twitter
people started calling out the people
that assaulted them start talking about
it and that gave others the courage to
do it see we know where that started
like cuz I know we had me to movement
several years ago and then this wave
kind of propped up no idea okay yeah
that I saw for sure the thing that I saw
was like a continuous thread of people
saying like I was and then like their
age and then in the location of when
they got sexually harassed so for me I
saw it I saw okay
kailani tweet about it and then like I
followed her cuz it's like quote
tweeting so it's kinda like a thread I
was I was confused because I saw that
too but I thought it was for a second I
thought I didn't understand what it was
I thought it was like because of the
whole black lives matter movement and
the George Floyd thing going on I
thought it was like how old I was when I
experienced racism and then upon seeing
it more I realized oh it was completely
something else so it was about sexual
assault which ladies I'm sure that you
guys have been through it before in your
life
yeah yeah sadly yeah I don't know
anybody who has it yeah I wasn't that's
it I haven't experienced a lot of it but
I do have one memory from work that I
have but that's about it
what was that so when I was in college I
got my very first kind of like real job
at a at a condominium I was like working
front desk and I try and transition into
accounting because that was what my
degree was in and the general manager
there at the time I guess he had a crush
on me and he saw that I wanted to do
more and get promoted and things like
that so we kind of took advantage of
that situation and he started asking me
to stay late with him for work to like
help him to help me learn some
accounting stuff after hours and then
eventually it turned into like after a
week he like was telling me how his
marriage wasn't doing well and all this
stuff and then it and then basically at
one point he cornered me in his office
and tried to make out with me yikes so
that was that I mean honestly that was
the the biggest and really
the only version of sexual assault I've
ever had I think I'm lucky because I
think a lot of women get it like much
younger family member like the way were
stories for sure um but how about when
you worked at Hooters like there was
never like any ass grabbing or any I
never really felt oh no not at Hooters
well if we're talking about ascribing I
think when I was like early 20s I went
to a club and someone grabbed my butt a
club but yeah I mean I don't know I
guess I that didn't affect me enough to
really stand out but yeah like this the
situation with my boss like that really
actually felt like that was nothing you
know ever it's yeah he's a power it hurt
me it hurt my knee like a small it did I
I remember thinking like oh is the only
way that I'm going to you know climb the
ladder and life is gonna be because men
find me desirable and I have to use that
part of myself to get the promotion that
I want or whatever so I remember coming
home and I had a boyfriend at the time
and I just started crying when I got
home and like he was just like what's
wrong and I was like I was just my job
sucks and I didn't even want to tell him
I felt embarrassed to tell him you know
yeah weird I remember thinking like [ __ ]
like this is the real world
you know I let's see I think you're not
alone in that and I think that's why I
like that it keeps getting brought up in
you know on social platforms because
that is a reason why a lot of people
don't speak up because we go well it's
not as bad as some other people that
I've yeah and I really do like that
everyone's sharing all of their stories
no matter how little it seems because a
lot of the men didn't even realize that
those little things were contributing
and I think that's what's more important
is that just like that be letting them
understand and be aware that it's not
just the person getting raped or the
person getting physically like overtly
assaulted it's these little things that
add up all microaggressions yeah yeah
causing you to in the long run believe
that you're less than and like believe
that you shouldn't speak up because you
don't want to hurt anyone's career or
you don't hurt their life you don't want
to cause a scene yeah right because I
mean
that too exactly you guys that's all
there Johnny though what's so that sauce
wound up getting fired because he slept
with like a board members wife I mean he
got he just was like crazy if you hadn't
come in anyway said nothing no wonder he
was having marital problems yeah yeah um
but I feel like the worst thing about
this is that it happens very young I was
seeing multiple tweets of people saying
I was like one digit age numbers which
is disgusting and I precinct tweeted I
was four years old wouldn't happen to me
you know and I remember everything from
like four years old to like random men
bowing their windows down and whistling
at me and honking at me when I was
walking home from school at nine years
old you know what I think what I
probably should not I could walk home by
myself like around 9:00 or 10:00 to
being at the arcade at ten years old and
an old man came over and like put his
hand in my hair and sniffed me yeah it
was Scott he did the never mind
yeah or like I remember when I was a
pageant girl I was second runner-up in a
pageant when I was 17 and you know we
were all having dinner at a like a
council member a council members house
remember like all the pageant girls
there I would say bathroom upstairs and
he liked ping me and he shoved his
tongue in my mouth oh honey I was over
17 he was like 30-something almost 14
yeah or like people grabbing you at
nightclubs it could be son like that or
I remember my old manager at the
restaurant that I worked at like try to
like hold my hand while I was hosting
and the front data because this but you
don't know when you're like when that's
what you're experiencing all of your
life and then it happens in a corporate
setting you just think like oh well this
must be how it is here too and you just
kind of shut up about that too um you
know and then and then for Eugenia like
you know you said it happened in a
pageant setting or like where it used to
work or like maybe when you were a
dancer I feel like people use that
excuse to of
well like you like it yeah you were
going that route like great like you
were dressing that way you were inviting
and touch attention you must not wanted
it and I think that keeps a lot of
people silent too so there's a lot out
there keeping people silent and not a
lot out there being like hey you should
speak up in fact there are a lot of
people who have spoken up and there I
find more and more cases of people
speaking up and saying that nobody
believed them that they were told they
were a liar especially if they're a
child speaking of so now it's a get the
courage to even speak up and then be
told you're a liar and you need to shut
up and you're stop spreading lies I saw
this tweet they kind of put it into a
funnier perspective for me it was like
it's like a room full of guys like
someone says oh that girl's a ho they'll
all believe that statement but if you
know and a group of you know guys if a
woman says he raped me that none of the
guys are gonna believe it or something
like you kind of have to think like why
would you believe that the woman is a ho
versus that the man did something wrong
so much easier it's weird yeah because
the how its processed I mean like a lot
of most times the rapist won't suffer
any consequences because you have you
have to prove it and you have to go
through a lot to prove it meanwhile if
you can't prove it they can make your
life a living hell for speaking out
about it so not only that but I feel
like it's just been so ingrained in like
the history of humanity where it's it's
been passed on like generationally where
like a lot of the in a lot of homes
listen in like the neighborhoods that I
grew up in and people all around me
every single woman in my life had gone
through some sort of experience like a
sexual harassment experience sexual
trauma and so when I was little I
actually thought that most women were
just put on this planet just to go
through these experiences like I was I
remember thinking when I was so young
like hating being a woman cuz I'm like
[ __ ] this is not fair that we have to
put up with this and I thought that we
had to put up with it like I really
thought that there wasn't like I had
never met any woman that had never been
through anything especially in their
when they're childhood though like this
is what I'm talking about like a lot of
this happened in our childhoods and I
just thought everyone was tainted and
everyone was just meant to to be tainted
and we just had to put up with it and
stay silent and and live your lives as
if nothing's wrong but I always felt so
tainted I did and I just it goes to show
how women are treated in society and
I've always told people for a longest
time like I'm terrified if I were to
have became to be a daughter you know
I'm so scared of having a daughter is it
so scary out there because you never
know who's gonna be could be it's not
always a stranger's most of the time a
lot of times it's your own family
members trust in people let me know you
know and that way and that leads to
another point I really want to really
stress is that if a child ever tells you
that they're uncomfortable around any
adult that all please believe them and
don't be like don't be silly go give him
a hug you know like don't [ __ ] do that
a joke what does wanting help them
absolutely take that seriously do not
work something out with them or you're
not good at all like we have a friend
who has a daughter and she's really shy
she doesn't like hugging or kissing or
nothing and I'm like [ __ ] a girl like
stand your ground and I don't get forced
like if you don't want to do it then
good like I'm just like hell yeah I
applaud that like encourage that
behavior like I mean but most parents
it's like oh come on like you know
whatever cuz they they see it from an
innocent lens but yeah I mean knowing
that this is so common and like it
happens often like we do have to like
protect her our girls and not just girls
but boys too like for example its Isaac
ever since he was like as young as I
could like I had always asked him and
always made that like number-one
priority like please tell me if anyone
has ever told you to touch them or
someone has done anything to you or like
if you were accidentally curious or
something I'm just like please please
please cuz that has been my number one
biggest [ __ ] fear is like anything
happening to my son cuz like I said this
should happen to me when I was way too
young
it was way I was I was waiting I
literally have a laundry list of stories
I can tell you guys and there is just
it's
it's it's too much yeah it just sucks
and is it too much to talk about those
stories because you know all these
things we were just saying about how
they you know how it's just a lot in
life to talk about to talk to actually
speak up and then when you do speak up
there's a lot of consequences that
happen from it yeah I mean I can get
into it a little bit I think it's more
healing for me I think like to just like
stop like bottling it all up in coz I
did like open up about one instance on
the podcast but I'll start from the
youngest I was um I think I was like
three or four the first time that like
as far back as I can remember when
something like this happened to me and
it was actually my babysitter's house
and my babysitter's father was the one
who had me like going to his pants and
like feel it him up and I didn't know
what she was that he literally had me
doing that and like I I remember like
freezing and feeling like I wanted to
scream and cuz I could see my babysitter
in the kitchen and we were in the living
room like I can literally see her and he
had me doing this and I'm just like I
couldn't speak like I couldn't say
anything and I was I'm telling you I was
like three or four and I knew even then
it was wrong especially the way he was
just so secretive and like so like oh
yeah and then she'd it's just it was
disgusting and I I did eventually end up
telling my mom and my mom I I don't know
the full extent of the details but she
did tell me that she pressed charges and
he did get arrested hey they put him
away oh wow it's a big Carter's mom
wasn't to you that time but oh no yeah
cuz like then I was I was 11 the next
time that it was like the most traumatic
because in between all these ages I mean
and in my I hate to say that I hate to
bring attention to this because I love I
[ __ ] love my culture so much but it's
so engrained in the Mexican culture for
older men to like look at little girls
in like it's it's so normal like
pedophilia is just [ __ ] normal and so
I remember being like really little and
constantly getting like
like sexual kind of looks from older men
and me thinking I remember thinking when
I was like six years old thinking like
like am i sexy like Irish it's just
[ __ ] weird like I would constantly
get these these these looks and like
like getting whistled at and like
walking down the street because I also
walked home alone like in the third and
fourth grade and so it's just a lot of
experiences but like the next horrible
one was when I was um I was 11 and it
was a family member and he came into my
room after he had been drinking and he
pretty much like he would always do this
disgusting [ __ ] grooming thing I
think it was like I think I could label
that but like he would always like like
rub my back and tell me how soft my skin
was and like how how delicate I I am and
like it was just so and I would be like
really uncomfortable but I like you
freezing those moments like especially
as a child yeah I'm supposed to do so
mine also isn't developer doesn't even
company what's going on or put it into
words
it just merely was wrong like I just
knew like deep down like this isn't
right and I don't feel good but I didn't
know how to get myself out of the
situation but anyway so then that time
when he came into my room really drunk
he was again doing the whole caressing
my back thing and then slowly he moved
to the front and started fully going in
on my nipple is an areola it's a point
like that I I am like to this day like
it literally is [ __ ] traumatic like
it affects you know our sex life like
that's why I can't really have him go in
there so I'm like I don't know it's
[ __ ] traumatic so so that's the
moment that's the [ __ ] is that like
you don't get to speak out on that and
have that guy face consequences but you
have to deal with all the consequences
of his action actually he doesn't look
traumatized by it he does yeah sit there
and like bring he knows about me like he
had
fun time for a day or whatever a couple
hours an hour so and then he goes and
forgets about it but for you it's a
lasting event that made an impression
forever and impacts everything in your
adult life yeah and like like I've I've
got a therapy for this and the therapist
has asked me like we'll have you press
charges have you like tried to get
justice and and like what you're saying
that Keys just really um it's really
hard to go out and do that because
there's a lot of like collateral damage
like pull there also how do you prove
all now after all this time like people
how are people gonna like rally behind
you it's like everyone's just gonna like
brush it off you know yes and not only
will it cause collateral damage by just
coming out with the story and going the
process of pressing charges but also if
you don't win it was like almost like
all for nothing because that guy in it
doesn't get punished for it and then
again you have to deal with the
consequences not to mention you have to
dig up your own trauma to even go
through it to press the charges yeah
yeah and so I mean that person in my
life had remained in my life and so
growing up like going through puberty I
would wear the heaviest sweaters and the
like in the middle of a summer because I
just didn't want him to like see me
getting developed and he would even poke
fun at it he'd be like Oh what are you
were that cold and I'm like it was just
constant I couldn't get away from that
and and then like yeah it's like your
own mom or anything or well that's
unfortunate that's the unfortunate thing
that I did tell her and she didn't
believe she believed him and I don't
like my mom has like a whole another
thing to deal with some fully fault her
anymore I think I've grown out of that
but for many years I really held that
against her but as you know I I
understand why it happened the way it
did but um moving on and how you know to
like
protecting of Isaac and because I have
very little girls in our group and
stuffing those protect them it's after
you know what I went through I remember
my I don't go not to use my friend so
she has a good anymore daughter it's
really small - go ahead fire solder yeah
my moms like no she's old enough you can
do it by yourself but I know that this
can happen at anytime in like same with
anyone you know with anyone like people
might think like a woman won't do that
oh yeah some because like the Butte like
the victim becomes the abuser and a lot
of cases and that's why I think like
that's what I'm saying it's like
generational like it just ends up
happening because it happened to you so
that you think this is okay and like
you'll do to someone else and I don't
know it's just it's so twisted but like
I feel like I feel like obviously I do
feel like some sort of guilt cuz I feel
like I am kind of part of the problem as
well by not bringing justice and not
likely not know that's a victim-blaming
thing that people do where it's like
well did you press charges like it's all
on the victim to have everything work
out and it doesn't work out even with
even with people who get a rape kit
immediately after they've been raped and
they submit of the evidence even even
those people have trouble getting
justice against rapists so it's like you
kind of feel like I guess this is just
something we're supposed to deal with
and sweep it under the rug or it's just
part of it comes with the territory and
that and that's what sucks and I think
that when people share their stories
like this even in this kind of setting
even without naming names or pressing
charges Italy skibs a little bit of a
healing where we're coming together
being like you're not alone if this has
happened to you you're not alone in this
you don't don't feel like this is your
your battle to fight along like we've
all been in different situations like it
and I think you know because part of
part of it is though when you stay
silent
you don't hear anyone else talking about
it you start to blame yourself - yeah I
mean that kind of like the point where
I'm at I think I can I can say with
confidence that if you've ever been a
victim of an assault or sexual like
great-granny think that it is pretty
much never your fault and ever 100% ever
your fault see she'd never think that
way - I know a lot of people struggle
with that like oh maybe I didn't fight
hard enough or maybe yeah I was drunk
maybe I was dress like this that's not
your [ __ ] fault dude you would
literally be butt-ass naked with ping
pong balls flying out of your coochie in
the middle of Times Square and you're
still not at night for it in an
invitation for any it's not an
invitation dude not how you act not how
you dress nothing like that yeah hey
guys um I don't really have a really
clever segue for this because it is a
really heavy subject I feel like we
shouldn't be talking about it so I just
want to take the time to give a shout
out to our sponsors honey my sweet baby
honey's listen we all shop online a lot
especially not during quarantine but did
you know you can make online shopping
even better you can save money with me
some plumber I love the name honey is a
free online shopping tool that saves you
money online it automatically finds the
best promo codes and applies them to
your cart which makes it so much easier
to find a deal and it saves you so much
money so all you have to do is when you
go to your favorite sites like Target
Best Buy Sephora when you check out this
little box drops down all you have to do
is click apply coupons and then honey
will start searching for all these
coupons all across the basket ball of
wide web and within a few seconds it
will scan area code and you and it'll
apply it and you can watch the prices
drop so the browser extension that us
know and then we will do that
automatically for you yeah
so the honey personally saved me a lot
of money because I've been shopping a
bunch because there is nothing else to
do and it makes me feel good I was like
you know yeah they spent $600 on like a
pair of nail clippers
then I say it's okay nail clippers
I'm saving something all right thanks to
honey
so honey has found its users over 17
million members it's found two billion
dollars in savings for their users
that's some one of them Sumerian that's
a lot of dollars okay mmm not using
money is literally passing up free money
it's free to use and install so just a
few seconds plus it's now part of the
PayPal family so you know it's legit get
honey for free ads join honey dot-com /
mood again get it for free at join honey
calm slash slash mood and then if you're
not bougie like Jeana spending six
hundred dollars on toenail clippers well
you do want your own stylist or someone
to help you pick out clothes and look
more fashionable in bougie highly
recommend stitch fix
okay so stitch fix here's how it works
you go to the site you get to fill out a
profile you kind of like they'll show
you pictures of different clothing items
you say if you like it or if you don't
like it and from there it gets to know
your tastes it goes they assign you to a
personal stylist and then the stylists
will pick out outfits that they think
that you'll enjoy and then they send
them right to your door so you don't
even have to leave your house to go
shopping and you trying on what what
they sent you you look in the mirror you
feel yourself if you ain't feeling
yourself you're like you know what maybe
I'll send this one back
you can keep as much or as little as you
want you pay a $20 styling fee for each
fix which is credited towards anything
that you keep and then you also get a
discount if you purchase all five items
in the box you could schedule at any
time there's no subscription required so
plus shipping returns and exchanges are
always easy and free this fix does the
hard work for you making great style
effortless for everybody including women
men and kids so get started today at
stitch fixed calm / mood and you'll get
25% off when you keep everything in your
fixed that's stitch fixed calm / mood
for 25% off when
keep everything in your fix stitch fix
comm / mood I personally love the jeans
there's our key make sure you you say
like to all the pictures of jeans I
never knew that there were good jeans
and stitch fix it I had no idea every
woman that I know and so I loved it
so stitch wix.com / mood but like I saw
a lot of like it's so barbaric I mean
I'm still seeing comment saying oh well
maybe you shouldn't put yourself in this
situation maybe you shouldn't have drink
a lot of women saying yeah
a lot of women yeah I think that's why
you're probably feeling that guilty
themselves that it has happened so they
probably it's like the victim blaming as
well for themselves so they're
projecting it I don't know completely
against that but I think the the people
who say that I want to believe that at
least half were more than half of them
feel like we have to live in the world
that we live in so you have to be aware
of certain dangers and not just
completely ignore it like you wouldn't
go into a gang-infested neighborhood
wearing the wrong color because you know
like there's consequences for walking
into danger so in certain situations as
women we have to live in the real world
and know that if you're gonna be
completely [ __ ] trashed at a frat
party in a city you've never been in
like it could be dangerous so consider
covering your cup consider doing all
these things it's not to blame the
victim but it's just to say like hey we
have to be aware right of the day but
it's never you at all yeah sure it's
definitely like smart to protect
yourself and have certain precautions I
think when people hear that message jazz
and I'm not saying like you don't say it
well or anything and yours that like
certain people like will twist it and
say well we shouldn't even have to do
that to begin with of course and that is
there's a real world like real world
look exactly I totally agree with what
you're saying just for sure yeah and
yeah it would be beautiful if we didn't
have to do this to begin with like
enough
I'm saying like it really starts at home
and like you it's really about educating
your son it's it's about breaking the
cycle and and hopefully like eventually
we're working towards that world where
we don't have to worry about this [ __ ]
and he's one of your kids not to take
advantage so nice to understand that I
know I can understand it as in like for
instance for me on what worse thing is
that saying like oh we should have been
drunk is like saying well if you didn't
want to get your house robbed maybe you
shouldn't buy things to rob
yeah yeah but also at the same time what
just sailing would you don't want to get
robbed
don't go somewhere like the dirty [ __ ]
watching arrested diamonds and gold
right I got it right right but it does
start at home you teach your kids like
don't do these things to people like
they're not asking for it you shouldn't
keep your financing yourself you know
yeah yeah those conversations as often
as I can with Isaac because I'm like is
it's horrible because sometimes he'll
have like a friend make like a certain
like comment and just and then I'm like
oh hold on no no that's not okay and you
shouldn't be viewing women like this
they're not right something you can just
like joke out or honk at or laugh at and
like we're [ __ ] human too and like I
try to go in on him like as much as I
can whenever I catch that and not even
just when I catch it but like I try to
like cover all the bases and just be
like please Isaac don't grow up to be
one of these men like I think you bigger
something bigger a bigger picture of all
that is Jamal that's you like the
maintenance issue that cover you always
how do you suck people period there be a
man or men just anyone it's sticking up
for each other so like if you see it
happening if someone if someone's doing
that to to jump in and put that person
in check for sure exactly what I tell
them as well because I have this one
little friend who makes these comments
quite often and I'm like King like you
just so you can't laugh with them meet
there I know it's lucky I'll be like the
downer but you gotta educate your your
friend if you see that that moment you
know like yeah do you ever feel like
mom like you need to like kind of have a
conversation with that kids mom or dad
because I mean it's almost like how do
we help the the kids you know it's like
like kind of like it so the village
raises the kids right so it's like hey I
don't mean to be super weird but your
son's kind of making these jokes just so
you know like maybe I deal with it
I am that mom yeah sessions I literally
have those conversations I really do it
because I'm like I feel so strongly
about this that I'm like I can't see the
next generation like especially in the
immediate circle at whatever I can do to
help it like it can't see the next
generation doing the same [ __ ] that are
generations and the generations before
us did like I can't just sit by and see
that happen and I hate those parents
really shut the [ __ ] up you know like
that right I hate that because they
actually extend that all the way to like
they do think in their twenties will be
boys no that's ridiculous I feel like
what they should be taught is speaking
up doesn't make you like the downer or
like the late guy I should make you more
of a man like a better person in general
you know yeah just speak up in this
that's where the change is gonna happen
like the real time has to happen when
people when they're young when they are
taught from the beginning that this is
wrong and they start you know putting
each other in check so that everyone's
on the same page but I'm not saying
that's easy no I don't think it's easy
and honestly I do feel like young boys
they kind of almost desire someone to be
a leader in their friend group and like
they all kind of they're like yeah those
girls or whatever but then like I've
seen situations amongst young kids young
boys in particular tours like if someone
comes up and acts more like a leader and
they're actually already respected by
their peers and they act a certain way
then all the other boys will follow and
they kind of like appreciate having
something to rally behind that's that's
like more respectful even though a lot
of kids are little [ __ ] but I've
witnessed situations where like I know
these younger generations like they they
feel good actually having something good
to believe in so I do I do a lot very
possible yeah bring out of their love so
if you have a beacon they'll follow it
or not it does take someone that
confidence and and knows that has a
strong grounding on what's right because
Steve was that for his peers like
growing up and putting his brothers in
check and he told me about certain
instances when they'd go out to like him
and his girlfriend went out to a club
one night and this guy was reaching
under girls skirts and like grabbing
their butts baby
yeah and Steve went over and like yelled
at that guy called already got him
kicked out you know so there are guys
like that and I think that if that just
continues to get spread that that's a
good thing that that that's not looked
down upon that's not from you know run
upon them that they're nice guys can see
like you know it's like let's see that
guy back like if backlash on Steven and
that guy's like oh you [ __ ] ass well
you [ __ ] what you're gay or something
whatever yeah then it's like then that
like I hope like other people around
could see how that person is just so in
the wrong where they make that the bad
thing and not Steve standing up for
what's right the bad thing cuz a lot of
especially in like our generation like
being good having good grades like being
like someone that was a good person it
was lame yeah cool square you don't want
to follow that it's just like what the
hell you were a nerd and all this [ __ ]
for sure yeah but I'm like that's
already changer yeah that's getting
point I know I feel like we're on a good
path right now but yeah I wanted to talk
more just like personal experience too
just because um I don't know what the
solution is or what the best answer is
but I know that for me like there's
definitely been all those little sexual
harassments wolf whistling and
catcalling you going to work and like
having guys call you sexy and just like
brushing it off because you don't want
to cause a scene there's a bunch of
those that add it up but then two in
particular that were beyond just you
know sexual harassment that I didn't
really speak up about ever publicly or
press charges or anything was because
one was a situation where I felt he was
in power and I was very scared of him
and I he was supposed to be my
representation but he would talk all the
time about how he could he had lawyers
and he it's not about what happens it's
about what you could prove in court that
happens and more than a handful of times
he kissed me on the lips knowing I had a
boyfriend and as I'm like actively
trying to pull back and be like yeah but
I'm as soon as I was like don't I don't
like that he'd he'd flip and be like oh
yeah so that's how it's gonna be like
that kind of attitude and I was so
freaking scared I was in this contract
with this guy this was in my very very
young 20s and I was in a con I was in a
5-year contract with him which who
[ __ ] has a five-year contract and I'm
Dona hon I'm dumb for not having a
lawyer read it but like I felt like it
felt like a mountain was on top of me
that like I didn't know anything about
the legal system or how contracts work
or how to get out of it I had a lawyer
try to get me out of it he said it
wouldn't work like basically I signed a
very very rustle yeah one there's a like
morals clause or yeah no I think he had
worded this he knew what he was doing
the way he worded this was like so
barely getting away with it being legal
but I did the worst thing about a creep
and the worst thing about a creep isn't
very smart creep yeah and I don't even
think it was that smart but he was smart
enough to have smart people tomorrow
that he hired yeah and he would
constantly remind me that um he had that
power and that he could take away
everything that I have if I ever tried
to fight him he also after every single
audition that I didn't book would tell
me that it was because I was fat and
untalented and that I needed to yeah
because I he's like I'm begging you or
something
yeah
Oh yikes also wouldn't want to be his
daughter or his ex-wife but he did that
too not just married but yeah and he
daughter is treating women this way geez
and he had mostly strong women that he
would sign like they were very like
pretty independent like good like I
liked all the people that he had son but
then he would break them down and it was
almost like he got off on breaking them
down or something and so I never spoke
out about that one because well I ended
up countersuing for sexual harassment
but I've signed an NDA so I can't ever
like say his name or like put it out
there but then also the other the other
guy I fell into that trap of being like
well I love him you know
and so like he would do horrendous
things and I would be like I somehow
asked for that or like so he was your
boyfriend
mm-hmm oh yeah and then that's harder
because like well he's your boyfriend
but yeah like one time I was sleeping
that's just one of the times I was
sleeping it was like 3:00 in the morning
I was dead asleep and you know I mean
like I fall so you're like freaking 10
like it's like I was dead asleep at 3:00
a.m. but he liked to go out he came home
he lived with me and he came home and I
just remember um he dumped like a cup of
water on me like dumped the whole thing
on me while I'm sleeping in bed and then
I woke up to him stripping me naked and
he started like finger-banging me and I
hate fingers by the way I [ __ ] hate
fingers but that's not even relevant
because that's not okay no matter if
even if I like two fingers um it's not
okay and I was just like I was not ready
for that my body was not ready for that
I was not prepared I was like so
confused at what was going on cuz I was
like dead asleep
I was completely traumatized by he
carried me to other side of the room and
left me there naked and then he went to
sleep and I was just so [ __ ]
traumatized I thought that or something
I don't know maybe probably uh maybe
drunk maybe
oh so sick like odd he's never done
something like that before it has we had
only been dating for six months so like
I just didn't I didn't know how to react
because he'd always come across as
like very sweet guy that like respected
women but then like little cracks
started showing and I was like what
about this what about this and then that
happened and and I end up spending the
night in my car in Hollywood in a
parking lot because I was I felt more
safe there that's crazy in my that's
very dangerous yeah it was at like
several people knocked on the window
during god I was it was bad and it was a
place set him on fire it wasn't a
private parking lot either it was a
public parking lot in Hollywood
you should just drag into Santa Barbara
so many times during this relationship I
wanted to I or I did I also call my mom
every day like crying because of
whatever when I found a journal where he
like basically bragged about every girl
he's like taking advantage or he would
trick or Gaslight or you know he kind of
got off on like being holding power over
women and then the last thing I remember
about him I won't get in all the
incidences but we were we've been broken
up for a day and I was still I still
like had feelings for him I mean I was
an abusive relationship but I like had
feelings for him still and so I brushed
it off but it was my birthday I got
hella [ __ ] drunk like so wasted that
like my friend was gonna take a taxi
with me home and then he offered to do
that instead so he took me home in a
taxi
and when I just remember he I remember
barely like getting into my apartment
and then I woke up to him having sex
with my unconscious body and I was like
well home I mean like at least maybe he
still loves me then you know and like
looking back now I am just like
horrified and shocked and just like I
can't believe I let that happen or that
behavior like I justified it in my head
is me being like well maybe like I maybe
I was drunk and led him on right before
that moment like Mike cuz I don't
remember what happened I just remember
waking up to that so there's a lot that
I'm like I would want to warn people
about him but I also he's kind of become
stalker and I don't want him to like be
in my life at all so yeah you know a
similar situation to like with my ex
with the whole like he would do this
like I literally lost count of how many
times he did this but there would be so
many mornings I wake up and he was
already like inside of me or he'd be
fingering me and like the most
disturbing thing too is that like as I'm
like you know like you when you're kind
of like waking up like you kind of move
a little bit I'd be doing that to get
him to stop and he'd freeze like oh [ __ ]
she's waking up and then like I wouldn't
move for like another like solid minute
or two and then he start again like he
knew what he was doing and he knew that
it was because I was asleep
and this actually got to the point where
I said like you are no longer allowed to
sleep in my bed you can't sleep over
anymore like we can't I don't even know
how the [ __ ] we even had a relationship
but right this literally like it was it
was so like traumatic to me that again
it literally affects our art like my
marriage by our sex life cuz like
morning sex is awesome you know like
great you know it's it sounds there's
all these little rings that are like
that are normal but then I into this
this way that trauma were you were
crossed the line that song times when I
told my ex like I am asleep I am NOT
giving you consent this is practically
raped like this is rape he's cannot
[ __ ] do this to me and then he'd be
like okay I promise I will do it I
promise okay whatever he was really good
at manipulating me and convincing me
that he was genuine so I guess I always
felt like like like deep down inside
like there was like a like some goodness
or like he's still want truth he doesn't
really yeah like you oh yeah I I kept
trying to convince myself and so I let I
give them another chance and then again
that morning the same things happening
again and I'd be full of rage where I'm
like I don't know how to I don't know
wonder if it's hard for people like that
to understand like why it's not okay
because like how do you continue to do
something that someone tells you
to do it's like they think we got over
it because we because so well it's for
me and it sounds like for you too like
when they're you want to believe that
there's good in them
this guy would buy me gifts after any
time there was an incident he would buy
me gifts and I and he would have this
like long no about how much she loved me
and like how he respects me and stuff
but then it would happen again because
it's like oh okay I'll forgive you then
because I believe that you did you made
a mistake but then they after enough
time goes by it's like they think oh
we're all it's it's fine now it's like
sure yeah and then they do it I guess it
kind of goes both ways for me too
okay guys sorry I've got to interrupt
for another sponsor we love our sponsors
they keep the show going this week we
have a brand new one and it is Roman
roamin is a product that will help men
last longer in bed and now I know what
you're thinking this is an awkward ad
for this type of episode but you know
what guys Roman respects women we they
respect healthy sexual activity and so
do we and we love Romans consented
sexual activity and we love Roman they
have a product called the Romans swipes
they are a clinically proven way to last
longer in bed they're effective easy to
use and fast-acting but they don't
require a prescription this is a little
bit different from viagra and it's not
really like that this is just gonna help
you
you know last longer during sex so you
can try these they ship in a discreet
unmarked package and each swipes packet
is small enough to hide in your wallet
for whenever you need it
they will not transfer to your partner
so you can last longer without worrying
and it's super easy to use just take it
out of the packet swipe it on let it dry
and you're good to go
the folks at Roman which is a men's
health company are changing the game if
you want to try these get $10 off your
first order of swipes and free 2-day
shipping at Roman comm slash big mood
that's get Roman comm slash big mood for
$10 off and free 2-day shipping again
get Roman calm
/ big mood that's right and if you're
looking for a fun way to pass the time
while engaging your brain and enjoying
some breathtaking visuals and a gripping
story your answer is my favorite best
fiends guys so it is a free download
so it says really cool and exciting
puzzle experience unlike any other
puzzle games out there because best
fiends they actually update their game
monthly with new levels and events so it
literally never gets old have you
noticed that I've been getting more
intelligent over these past few months
because I've been exercising my brain
you know telogen that way okay but
you're really yeah but best fiends
really has exercised my brain I get more
articulate now but ya know I also love
this game because of the fact that it
does not require internet to play so
back when I was doing a lot of traveling
this was my go-to game on the airplane
and they also have like tons of
characters you could collect all these
cute little fiends and they you can use
them strategically for each level
because they have different powers and
all these things so engage your brain
with fun puzzles and collect tons of
cute characters trust me with over 100
million downloads this five-star rated
mobile puzzle game is a must play
download best fiends free on the App
Apple App Store or Google Play
that's friends without the are best
fiends download it now and thank me
later
mmm to you specifically so that you
don't like that and you kept going but
for me in different ways I actually like
that
look the thing the difference is my
event consent like I remember a dating
the time he's I feel weird you just
think it okay good you thought about
that sounds good I'm like no no like I'm
into that
like totally 100% okay like it's fun
yeah I mean that's a conversation that
you've had in
it was like me and Casey like I had told
him like this isn't this is trauma for
me like I've literally lived with this
guy like he's been he had been doing
this to me for a solid two years
like year and a half he mentioned both
will turn off of it yeah like like I
would wake up screaming and like it was
it was horrible and so I would tell him
like this is the situation please do not
do this to me
and in case he would do it too and I'm
like dude come on but like I guess he
thought like I don't know what the [ __ ]
he's thinking and I got to it literally
had to get to the point where Steve was
like he just she just doesn't like that
like what why does it have to be in the
morning if that's not her thing like
just let it be and since then thank God
I'm like finally it's like that
conversation has it's like let's not
touch that right now like I'll let you
know when I'm ready like I'm still
[ __ ] like healing from years of this
[ __ ] and also years of like you are not
listening to me not knowing how how
important this what this is to me like
yeah I don't get it like even ordered
something this [ __ ] serious don't
[ __ ] care like there's so many times
when I'm sure you guys intelligent
nificant other overlooking please stop
doing this you know and I was like like
non related to sex like yeah please stop
she can did not give consent for you to
cut that chicken up yeah but it'll
become something as serious as someone's
screaming at you about it we'll see it
essentially well okay I gotta clarify
really quick yeah I got it I gotta
clarify the whole Casey thing too it's
um
he was like this is I believe him okay
but he says like you know he just he
doesn't realize he's actually doing it
and they filed all like move I'll wait
like I'll push him off whatever he does
stop like he doesn't continuously do it
like the other guy was malicious yeah I
don't know a lot of guys like doing that
in that moment kind of before you wake
up like I've had countless guys like
they'll be touching and they're they're
just like they're kind of waking up with
the boner and it's like kind of an
innocent like they're not trying
without what your ex was like he was
like doing it because you were asleep
that is the clear distinct leer like
that was bad this one is like oh [ __ ]
like he's trying not to but yeah
consciousness like I understand that but
he has stopped so I don't know a book
happen there but yeah I'm feeling like
they're mixed messages cuz I hear that
from guys a lot like oh yeah that's just
because like you know some girls they
say no but they mean yes or whatever
like they like they deal with different
personality types I think the clear
thing you have to listen for is consent
like and and maybe we've had a
conversation like oh you know I like it
when you know you dominate me and I
don't have to say anything then we've
had that conversation before
and that's still consent but if if you
are getting clear signs like body
language - while you language of like no
I don't like that or no I'm not into it
then that is that should be your clues
that that is not okay it's not good I
think most normal guys kind of get that
it's just the it's so creeps in the
weirdos like that TIFF was dating who
like she said no a thousand times and he
still did it so telling them literally
it means doesn't help it would get to
the point where like if he like let's
say we were hanging like with max we
were hanging out really late and he's in
my apartment and like she was drinking
and you just didn't want to drive home
whatever the [ __ ] I'm like you're
sleeping in the living room and I'd lock
my door like that's how you shouldn't
have easy a guy you should never date
someone like that yeah oh god girl well
yeah that's why I like looking back it's
like wow how did I let myself get into
that situation I do a lot of therapy
about like codependency let that type of
stuff because if you like a lot of
behavioral patterns or history in people
who are codependent you had someone in
your life who was narcissistic that you
learned to almost people please you know
and and so that's how codependency gets
created and if you could break it though
like you can break codependency and so I
think that was what was happening was I
just the way that I thought I was
receiving love was wrong yeah and
you want me in and you want to believe
they're a good person because well we
had all these bedtime so they are yeah
exactly in a bit and you start making
excuses
he doesn't know so that it races all the
shitty [ __ ] that they do and it's not
okay for me I think I'm my own therapist
I really feel like a lot of the
situation's I was in was because like I
said it started when I was so [ __ ]
young I was three four years old and so
since then I had always felt like I
wasn't I wasn't deserving of anything
better like I thought this is what I
like this is just the hand I was dealt
and this is just what I had to deal with
like too bad Tiffani sorry like and so
that's why I was I was in too deep tip
because I just felt like I'm not good
enough to have better and yeah it was
like there's a lot of um like self hate
I think because of the fact that I
thought that this is just my destiny
like I'm just destined to just always
suffer in one way or another you hadn't
built like a respecting yourself to like
know where to draw the line and know
what was okay it okay for you
safe bottom line for me is I tell my
sisters and younger he was just like
there's anyone that's touching you in
any way whatsoever that makes you
uncomfortable you don't want to follow
through you know some excuses make a
scene if you have to I really hate it
said people don't even notice that
they're doing this but I hate when like
I'm talking to a stranger or someone
like a guy to club he always said trying
to touch my arm like oh yes where you
from
oh did you want to like stop [ __ ]
touching me don't touch me you know like
some guys are getting mixed messages too
cuz like you know those uh
what are those big calls of guys that
like help other guys get women of
artists they that's one of the things
they tell those guys to do is like oh
they like like little signs of physical
touch like shows that you're interested
in stuff so it's like I just don't know
why they don't know when to leave the
room yeah yeah the [ __ ] room and
obviously I must put this up here we go
I don't care about the hate for this if
you use a pickup artist they're [ __ ]
lame dude like it's like you're [ __ ]
lame because I really really I like
if you have to use a pickup artist you
need to learn to love yourself and once
you do you will gain the confidence
where you can approach women it's not
about what's the tips and tricks like
all right let me read let me like video
amen
exactly yeah there's no manual totter
one thing always yeah exactly it's
really coming from a place of self-hate
like I've seen the way you have no
confidence I've seen these ads of like
oh gee we're gonna pick up women BOGO
and just like bro none of this would
have worked those are crazy features
I mean honestly there's a lot of because
I go through when we started this
podcast I like was consuming a lot of
content like because I was single for
the first time and I was like or like in
a dating and relationships podcast so
I'm like I was consuming a lot of
content on the male and female side
there's actually a lot of like really
respectful YouTube channels where guys
who need dating advice can get good
advice or good yeah pickup artist or the
advisors that are trying to give you a
legitimate advice and not let some sort
of cheat code into getting into panties
cuz that's like that's a situation where
you're probably gonna cross a line yeah
no that's what they do things like
negging where yeah I remember getting
negative negative yeah I got neg ones
and I was just like bro shut up suck
don't leave right yeah it's yeah um but
like I was saying earlier it's just like
if you ever feel like any just
uncomfortable about someone touching in
any way whether it be your [ __ ] boy
if I don't care if it's your [ __ ]
boys that you've been with for like ten
years you know like if there's some sort
of touching that's making you
uncomfortable and you are allowed to
speak up because you're still your own
person this is your body like I remember
back when what 1950s or something it was
commonly said that oh it's not rape if
you're married to him yeah I mean that's
that's [ __ ] stupid no it's still your
own body I don't care how long you've
been with this person what a male or
female because I'm comfortable you speed
up and get the [ __ ] out of there but I
do want to bring up the opposite of this
is that well I've seen quite a few
articles and I've seen
a few things on Twitter where people
make up stories
yes they don't happen to like this
person and there was a football a star
football player in high school that went
to prison for what six years because a
girl said that that she was raped by him
and six years in prison
later she finally convinced or confessed
that she made it up his life was ruined
his scholarship was taken when he's
never ever go to college dude knows that
but like the entire like this is the
actual Iman's like yeah they ruin
hurting your [ __ ] so during it for
people who have gone through this and
you're [ __ ] it up for everyone else
and I I truly feel that if someone works
you use this as a weapon and it was
proven then they should get a cruising
sentence - absolutely yeah totally yeah
you messed up someone's life that guy's
lifeless how he had someone in prison
for six years
Derby's most like impressionable year
feelings definitely a minimum of six
years or so absolutely especially I was
in court and she lied under oath like
isn't that something that they can not
only that guys but then to hear um there
was oh my god I'm so I'm really sorry
I'm blanking on his name but this little
boy from I think the fifties or sixties
14 oh boy yeah he was accused of like
sexual harassment and this is also like
you know a racial thing because he was a
black boy or take my name it's Oh No
yeah it was yeah wasn't he Kenny's just
like it wolf asleep it was something
like that but then you're not getting
there was a girl like there was a few
because there was one that was accused
of murdering two white girls and there
was one those accused of talking to
and/or whistling to a white woman
honestly there's thousands you know
young
yeah yeah what which got killed one of
them execution by the electric chair the
other one was dumped in a river like
lynched or something yeah that's just
horrid so like how do not into that like
how do we like what do we like yeah that
we do that's what's [ __ ] it up to is
yeah is that these false reports are
making the justice system harder for
actual victims to get any justice I
don't know I don't know that there's an
answer for that because there's always
gonna be crazy people like we can't we
can't preclude the fact that there are
literally mentally ill people that will
do things like that it's just we have to
have a certain standard for proof I
guess or something III it's hard but
there's nothing we can do to stop that
because you can't force the vehicle who
will show me proof and then a lot of
real cases would be drawn out yeah so
it's it's there is no clear answer to
this okay you know just don't [ __ ] do
it don't be a piece of [ __ ] ruin
someone's life just because of some
petty [ __ ] no so it goes both ways
and I feel like also we should really
stress the fact that this I really hate
that when it happens to men to little
boys i how many times have you heard a
news article like a little boy you know
teacher was arrested for having sexual
relations with her student and
everyone's like oh nice I don't think
that's now sparked Gambas oh yeah nice
you know like oh I wish I was my teacher
dude it's [ __ ] gross yeah you know
like really weird it's disgusting I
don't yeah so you know even we saw with
Terry Crews who I mean he's a little bit
of a problematic individual right now I
think but we saw when Terry Crews came
out he got a lot of like he got dogged
on like oh you're this big man how did
you let someone take advantage of you
and it's like can you imagine how many
other men some weird [ __ ] might have
happened to and they're never gonna
[ __ ] admit it because of that or like
they're just saying oh you know like
there are people who honestly believe
that men can't get raped yeah
geordie of men that get raped are by
other men too like it's like if there's
a lot of predator people that don't give
a [ __ ] what gender you are yeah but they
can't get raped by women Susak well he
got hard so clearly he wanted it it's
just like ya really don't understand
human anatomy do you yeah they use are
really [ __ ] stupid
like I I haven't really touched base on
my story because I do want it's been a
long time since it's happened and I yeah
it was a lot of collateral damage that
could have happened that's why I stayed
quiet about it for a little time I think
I am getting to the point where I am
ready to speak about it because I
because I feel like the more I speak
about it the more the more it helps and
it does good now instead of just damned
you ever told anyone there's also was
the first time because you tweeted I was
for like as a part of the movement so is
that the first time anyone in your
family has heard of that or do they know
whispers of something but they don't
know details or in the family everyone
knows ok family everyone knows publicly
it's always been hinted at but I never
really woods detail the family in the
family everyone knows because it took me
a long time to realize what happened to
me and then of course you don't have any
[ __ ] clue what the hell that is as a
job and then like I think I have
mentioned before that I'd cut off like a
whole half of my family whole side of my
family is because of that and upon like
being on Facebook I noticed that the
people that I did get a long look at
that family had children now and a lot
of them with little girls and I was like
[ __ ]
well [ __ ] like if I know something that
I should say something because if anyone
happens to those little girls I would
feel responsible I could have prevented
it you know so I did speak up I messaged
every single person that you know I a
long message like hey you gave him her
for me and like about 12 years but
here's why I left a family and all that
so you know thankfully all but one
believe me which is really weird because
the one that didn't believe me was my
attackers daughter what
I don't like me to think that I think
something may have happened with her to
also it could just be like as a daughter
you with your dad like this this like
he's my king and complex like my daddy
you know like I'm not going to leave
that situations like I think the mom
Mamas and Papas you know the that band
rock band yeah so I think it was that
bad but um I had heard that the girl
from a girl from that band she had been
was sexually molested and like rape like
her entire life by her dad and she
thought that that is how a dad shows
love to a daughter so then once like
another I think maybe I'm messing this
up maybe I'm mixing this story with
another story but by the time when
someone came to like a different family
member that got abused by this by her
dad she ended up saying like what are
you talking about like this is how love
is shown like what do you mean like this
is you know this isn't a room this is
that's exactly what that shows me love
this is like what happened when I spoke
out because I told all of his kids I
told his wife and his wife was like well
that that didn't happen and if it did
that's just how these people show love
and I'm like excuse the [ __ ] out of you
story yeah so you know I I spoke up
about it and you know almost children
knew he had all sons and one daughter
all the sons were livid like one of them
once go down there and kill him so I
have their support the daughter was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] she dies we don't know her
story though yeah well no no she was she
was a [ __ ] raging [ __ ] I don't care
I'm she dies I don't use that word often
either so you know I felt like I was I
had to speak up about it because I
didn't want to happen to any of the kids
and when I spoke about it you know a
bunch of other family members said you
know what we never liked him we kind of
had an idea this is why he left but the
Asian culture is so loyal to the head of
the family the man of the family like oh
yeah like they gave you everything so
you should never speak out you know
taking this disgusting Asian respect
thing and
holy we can't lose face nobody can know
this you know like they we don't want to
be embarrassed kind of thing they
similar in the Mexican culture yeah I
see news yeah so that's why I like his
wife protected him like no this this
would never happens that and so I ended
up I did confront them you know I
finally it took me years caballo only
did it like last year and I felt that
was a huge healing process for me but
fortunately he has died I hope it was
painful but you know that's a good I
hope he suffered every second of it so
that brought a little bit of peace to me
too but you know it it was something
that affected me for a long time in fact
my relationships if I didn't mind my
might like how I grew up my personality
how I developed and it's just something
that I knew owns you as a person it
really does it really doesn't it and
like Nicky said it's [ __ ] up because
then nothing happens to them we are the
ones who take the brunt of everything
and from childhood to adulthood you know
it's there all the time and you never
fully get rid of it but you do learn to
kind of I guess coexist with it the best
possible yeah yeah grow from it as much
as you can I mean be like well I guess
my I can take it and help others with it
which I hope that we do but yeah it's
always just kind of there yeah yeah you
know you take the dirty plant flowers
with it and that's what I want to do you
know I think I'm almost ready to come
out and talk about it's it's gonna be
quite a process but I like that saying
take the dirty plant flowers I just made
I like I like but you know I really this
is a this is a subject that I am so
incredibly passionate about because it's
something that I can relate to and I
know that all my eight my friends can
relate to so if you're watching this
right now and you're looking for a sign
or looking for that extra kick to really
take control of it finally to either
speak out or you don't have to be got to
get help for it or something yeah this
is the time to do it the sooner the
better
you didn't do anything wrong this was
not your fault it was never your fault
you are the victim here and this you if
you if you need someone to you know just
kick your buttocks
you know just go need to do is now then
please do yeah if I let strengthen your
trauma because I think for me personally
like I felt my trauma defined me and
held me down like I I really just let
myself get consumed with being a victim
like I was just like well this is just
my life this is what I have to go
through and this is it like but then
like I don't know like going to therapy
even in this moment like speaking out
about it and actually sharing my
experience like it's like you have to
grab that trauma and and find strengthen
it and come out the other end and be
lighter like it's just like you know
like no matter what it is that you do
it's either therapy or confronting your
abuser or or whatever it is I talk about
it so yeah just anything really ends up
you feel lighter you know he really does
hope this is an ongoing conversation
which is why I am happy that like it
does keep getting brought up on Twitter
and it's not just like I did feel like
kind of when the meets who movement
happen like oh I miss my chance to speak
out on it like because it's gone and I
don't I don't feel all alone again you
know but as long as it's an ongoing
conversation and people continue to
share stories and we feel like oh my
gosh we can get together we could you
know band together on this and stop
victim stop the victim blaming and stop
blaming ourselves and stop feeling
guilty for what was done to us
I think that's a step and you know
obviously this might be contrary to what
I just said to you but also at the same
time if you need to take your time
please do it yes exactly 30 hour too
late or too early like there's a lot of
arguments ago why do you take you so
long come on
a valid argument that's obviously um one
the most though the story I share this
is the first time I've ever shared it
ever publicly and that happened in 2012
so it's been eight years and I've never
said a peep about it except to Steve and
like maybe one or two people in my
circle but I've never publicly said it
and that's it just it's not on you -
like it's again that's another form of
victim living is like it's not on you -
everything is in your control you go by
your pace but you this is not who you
are
this doesn't define your whole entire
life your personality your value your
worth or anything but it is fully in
your control now if you can speak about
it whenever you want to take control and
you don't have to be a good to me
forever yeah we love you guys this was a
this was a heavy episode but necessary
and it's like flowers plant flowers dirt
your flowers yeah I hope you have a
great week daddy there's been a mood
mood move has been a big mood take care
buddy buddy one see you next week